Boom, and we're live. My man.
What's up baby? First of all,
how the fuck do you punched so hard?
I've seen hard punches, man. I've been
watching boxing since I was a little kid.
You've got some freakish power, man.
Weird. You've got weird power. Oh,
most definitely. Oh, we always
said I'm a freak of nature.
I definitely got some
type of freakish powwow.
I always tell the story that my
grandmother said I was anointed by God.
She was always like, if I got suspended
for school and stuff, she was always like,
God is trying to use you. You're
the one you're chosen. You know?
She was very big and you know,
she was big in the spirit,
spirituality and Christianity,
you know,
so she's always be a teacher. You
know? She wasn't really a discipline,
disciplinary type of woman.
She was a teacher.
She wanted to teach or tell you certain
things. She used to always say, oh,
I was annoying. She won't
even let my parents with me.
Well, not in front of her.
That's how serious you were. She like,
she like, don't you been not with him.
He's going to be the
one that bring you up.
He didn't want to be the one to bring
you guys up. Don't whoop him. You know,
somebody tells you something like that at
a young age, you might believe it. Well,
I didn't even realize that really, you
know, just being so young, you know,
just being, you know, we, we
would, we, we did as children do,
you know,
I didn't really think too much about it
because I didn't understand what she was
saying.
You know,
I ain't start understanding until you
start putting away child his ways and you
become a grown man.
You start a out in life and experience
in life on your own and started seeing
certain things. And then even, even when
I got out of my own, you know, I really,
it's a lot of things,
I didn't start understanding it until I
was 30 you know what I'm saying? Just to,
you know, cause certain things, different
things, what happened in my life,
you know, and that you, you know,
sometimes you just get you to you,
you deal with it and you handle
it the best way you can handle.
But there's certain things that
starts to happen. He was like,
my grandma said something about this
or, you know, just, you know, and um,
that's how my life been.
But it's amazing how I can come
in at two oh nine and finally,
God is that coming in the two system
and able to drop him like I did. Like,
it's crazy, but we are, I've always been
stronger than mine than what I've looked.
It's interesting that the cruiserweight
division doesn't get any love. I mean,
the last time I got lovers with
Evander Holyfield was fine. Yeah.
That was really the last time people
cared about the cruiserweight division.
Now it's a forgotten division.
Kinda almost. Yeah. Yeah,
that's true. You know, um,
you know, my brother is just
starting in the, in the,
in the cruiserweight division. Hopefully
he can bring some excitement, you know,
to it because you, you're
so right. You know,
it's almost like they
don't even talk about it.
It doesn't make any sense because the
light heavyweight division gets a lot of
love, love watching light. Heavyweight
sense always gets lots of attention,
but the cruiserweight division is
always like, people look at it like,
why are you here? Yeah. Find some
weight. Go Up. Yup. Yup. It's true.
It's true because the heavyweights
always overshadow those guys.